That's Tim Barnes over there.
He's a reporter.
Tim, this is Julia.
She's our new trainee.
Hi.
This is a very interesting story, Martha.
Look at this.
Oh, tell me about it this afternoon, okay?
Sure.
See you around, Julie.
Julia.
Sorry.
My name isn't Julie, it's Julia.
Oh, right.
And the address has got two Ds.
What?
Address is A - D - D.
Right, thank you.
Don't mention it.
Who's that young woman with Martha and Shawn?
Her name's Julia.
She's the new trainee.
She's very pretty.
Well, that's everyone, I think
Tea or coffee?
Coffee please.
Black or white?
Oh, white with no sugar please.
Hello, you're Julia aren't you?
Yes.
Pleased to meet you, I'm Gary.
Nice to meet you, Gary.
What do you do?
I'm a newsreader.
Oh yes!
You're Gary Fenton.
You're my mom's favorite newsreader.
Here you are.
Hello Gary, this is Julia.
Yes, I know.
Anyway, I must be off.
See you.
He's very nice.
Yes.